Yeah, well, one thing that I love that Kitchens for Good
does overall as a nonprofit,
I think really what our secret sauce is,
is the incredible investment we make
in each individual in our program.
I have always wanted to support or work for organizations
that really were about finding solutions
to overarching problems and the solution side of that.
So we're not just training individuals in a skill.
We're training individuals in culinary.
We are providing power skills
so that they are successful once they get a job.
We're helping place them.
We're continuing to work with them for as long as they need
to make sure that they are successful.
And it does take a lot of investment in each person,
but I would always rather be a part of that
than maybe something that helps people get through,
which is very valuable,
and then kind of doesn't address the wider issues happening.
And I really hope that what our donors get to experience
is a true connection with our organizations.
I always say, once you're a part of Kitchens for Good,
you're a part of our family
and we're gonna treat you like family.
And we are gonna bring you into the good, the bad,
the ugly, anything and experience that with you.
So we always wanna offer the opportunity
for our donors to come and visit us
and you're gonna walk in
and you're gonna walk into the kitchen
right into the dish pit.
There's gonna be, it's gonna be hot
and there's gonna be people yelling orders back and forth,
but you're gonna be a part of that.
We will have you come in and be a taste tester for us.
This is a school and it might,
it's not gonna be a five-star restaurant, but that's okay.
We want to bring you along with us.
We are not putting up a smoke screen.
We are not trying to have you wear your rose-colored glasses.
We want you to understand everything it takes
for our apprentices to have that transformation.
And we just have a lot of really great down-to-earth,
wonderful people who are supporting
what we're doing every single day.